now it's a pretty disastrous election
result for labor you're worse since 1935
what do you think went wrong well I've
been up and down the country already
speaking to voters and activists asking
a very same question I think it was a
combination of a number of factors first
of all our brexit position the time it
took to get to our ultimate position on
calling for a people's vote took a bit
too long I also think that we had a
manifesto which although was incredible
in parts nobody believed was actually
deliverable and the leadership came up a
lot on the doorstep you say there and
that you took too long in getting to
your position supporting a second
referendum some people would argue that
it was that position that you ended up
at it was the real problem if you look
at the seats where know you lost so many
voters it was brexit supporting seats in
the north and Midlands surely it was
that position not just the time it took
I think what people wanted was
leadership from us and we didn't show
that in enough time I think ultimately
saying that we would negotiate a better
deal and put it back to the people was a
good position to come to I mean look I
make no apology I was very outspoken on
the fact that I would not support
Theresa Mays deal I would not support
Boris Johnson steel and I believe that
we should put it back to the people but
we took too long coming to that position
as a party and as a result we lost trust
of people in both leave and remain seats
same time though and as you said you
know you've always been a supporter of a
the people's vote if you like or second
referendum is others call it and you're
an MP for London some people will be
looking you know at your candidacy and
thinking why would we need to get
somebody who is you Pro remain Pro it
from a London constituency when actually
the voters that we need to reach are not
those voters I understand that but
actually I make no apology for for
really supporting my community I knew
that leaving the EU would be worse off
for my community for jobs for local
businesses but I do wholeheartedly
accept that we are leaving the EU and
now the job moving forward is to stare
the Conservative Party in the eye to
look at Boris Johnson and stand up for
our workers rights our environmental
protections our security our food
standards
and as deputy leader that's the fight
that I will take that I will say this
Sophie I grew up in poverty I know what
hunger feels like I know it being cold
feels like and my lived experiences will
enable me to connect with voters around
the country
it hasn't matter that I'm from London so
it's not just you say it's more about in
the experience that you've had rather
than the location that you grow up -
absolutely and I work on our front line
NHS I'm fighting our government and cuts
every single day when I work as an A&E
doctor the Labour Party changed my life
it enabled a mixed-race woman from a
single-parent background whose mum had
to work three jobs to put food on the
table
- then despite failing her a-levels and
feeling like she was lost of all hope to
go on and go to Cambridge to study
medicine age 24 because a Labour Party
believed in her I want to stand for
deputy leader because I want to I want
to show every child in this country that
there's no ceiling on what they can
achieve there was a ceiling placed on me
and my family under Thatcher and major
governments and I'm determined to smash
that ceiling for all the children who's
you know for whom the door closed on the
12th labour failing those children now
Labour's not failing the Conservative
government have been failing in a loser
for the last election ten years Corbin's
we need a Labour government and you're
right
people didn't trust us to govern and as
deputy leader I'm going to go into the
communities up and down the country into
Scotland into Wales roll up my sleeves
Alec Ison and that's the pitch I just
want to bring it back to reality
slightly with the latest polling this is
the latest polling on the deputy
leadership poll from you gov you're
there an 80% yes way out in front
well 57% is Angela Rayner I mean on this
score she would win in the first round
what I mean is it effectively game over
for me well for all of you you've part
from Angela Raina it's never game over
it's never game over Sophie I've I've
been the underdog my whole life I've
always been told that there things I
can't achieve because of who I am and
where I come from I've never listened
before I'm never gonna listen now but
you know what the fact that I'm on the
show with you this morning if there is
one child that turns on the TV and says
oh my goodness she was poor she was
hungry she was cold she failed
she felt a void of hope but she's able
to go on and achieve and go from poverty
to Parliament if there's one child
that's influenced by my story it doesn't
matter that I'm on 8% because I'm
winning being right here getting those
messages out okay and I'm keen to get
your thoughts on the leadership contest
who do you want to win I genuinely will
work with whoever the leader is and I'm
actually the only deputy leader that
didn't nominate a leadership candidate
who do you want to win I don't have an
opinion at this point because I think
over the entire cabinet job with one of
the winners then listen would I love to
be in a she had a secretary state for
health given my NHS background given the
fact I'm fighting in A&E all the time
doing shifts of course I'd love that but
more importantly to hear women I think
it makes me the right person for the job
I would really like to see a woman at
the top of the party now but
fundamentally we have a rebuilding
process that is going to take years it's
going to require listening it's going to
require working together and it's got to
be about the best person for the job but
it's going to be exciting the next few
weeks seeing you know people setting out
their stall is it's yeah yes it's gonna
be interesting
okay I'm keen to are shoe quickly and
about a story that was in The Sunday
Times today it's about reports that
Jeremy Corbyn is planning to nominate
his chief of staff Kerry Murphy for a
peerage do you think it's appropriate
that someone so closely involved with
the last election campaign should be
elevated to the House of Lords I
personally don't know Kerry Murphy well
at all what I do know is that she's
currently being investigated by the eh
RC and I made clear yesterday that as
deputy leader I would take onboard every
single recommendation from the ear
eh r c-- news on allegations of
anti-semitism and how they were done yes
and hope not hey said that anyone who is
being investigated by the eh RC
shouldn't be recommended for a peerage
so I think that does need to be taken
seriously so you're a bit uncomfortable
with it I would like to see the outcome
of the EHR scene report and I don't know
Kerry Murphy personally okay now just to
finish I thought because you know not
all of our viewers will have a clear
impression of who you are we could end
with a little quick fire round okay okay
oh are you ready I'm ready are you ready
okay William and Kate or Harry and Megan
Harry and Megan
Love Actually or love Island Oh both I
like both yeah because I did the Love
Actually video but I do I do like love
Islands okay and boxing or football
boxing favorite member of the
Conservative Party
Tracy Crouch and political hero oh come
at Lee